let's go to the Friday Feed Bag someone
wrote to me and said David instead of
feedback Friday or Friday feedback you
should call it the Feed Bag like a horse
that eats out of a bag I don't know
listen folks I'm gonna go over some
messages that I received from people uh
significant reaction to the anti-trans
explosion from CPAC over the weekend one
message I received very much
representative of others Kyle said what
about all the rights the drag and trans
Community
is trying to take from all other people
so
I don't know what the hell Kyle's
talking about and I've heard this before
that the people's rights are being taken
by the the drag and trans Community
since Dragon Trends are two different
things let's maybe see if we can think
that through I can't even think of any
bad arguments that the drag Community is
taking anybody's rights I know the right
might say well
they're taking away parents rights not
to be around drag queens they're really
not and when you look at the details of
all of these drag time story hours and
whatever
parents are bringing their kids to them
so I don't understand how anybody's
losing a right there if anything parents
are continuing to have the right to say
here's what I want to show my kid or
here's what I don't want to show my kid
now as far as the trans community
I think or the argument they love to
make is if I quote have to call someone
by a certain pronoun
then I've lost my right of Free Speech
but of course that's not really the case
what we're talking about here is decorum
there are situations where States might
have a law for example with regard to
being able to change your driver's
license or at work changing your
employee file if you've transitioned or
but these things don't really have
anything to do with rights and it's sort
of like if you're just out in the world
and you don't want to use someone's
preferred pronouns it's not a question
of Rights it's just a question of
decorum and politeness the same way that
you could choose to use racist words
around people it's not a matter of
Rights it's a matter of how are you
going to treat others so as usual they
talk about Free Speech when it's not a
free speech issue they talk about rights
when it's not a rights issue okay a lot
of people don't like my analyzes and
coverage of trump speeches and rallies
Laura wrote to me and said you're
horrible it's the wrong you're
required it's the wrong you're you're
horrible making from of trump I assume I
assume Laura means making fun of trump
you're horrible my horrible making from
of trump the best ever get a life and
find another job you aren't funny fact
worthless she adds
my favorite thing I have to I know that
this some people don't like this my
favorite thing
is when
people hate
that this is my job
and it's a great job to have with tons
of great benefits and perks and the
ability to communicate with great people
every day and build a community so you
know what Laura I think I'm gonna keep
my job and if you don't like my thoughts
about Trump's speeches you don't have to
watch Cooper left the comment you're
free again it's the wrong your guys
you're free y-o-u-r-free
to do whatever you want as long as
you're prepared wrong you're to suffer
the consequences so keep on doing drag
shows for kids and you'll eventually get
what's coming to you
is this a threat of violence against the
drag performers because who's doing the
drag shows the drag performers and and
what on Earth could possibly be coming
to them they're not doing anything wrong
everybody's fine I was thinking the
other day talking with a friend of mine
you know
when my daughter is at whatever age she
might find
any of this entertaining would there be
anything damaging if she saw a drag
performer and I really couldn't think of
anything he just said what how would
that even rank how would that be
anything to even be remotely concerned
about so I don't know what the
consequences are going to be and I don't
even know what Cooper says the
consequences are to the people seeing
the drag shows it's all wild
abortion still an issue for many in our
audience David wrote In left a comment
and said what young people don't
understand is you will reach out to God
on your deathbed how will you explain
your stance on abortion or the abortions
you had you will reach for hope no
matter what in the end
David
I'm ready to make a promise to you today
I am never never never
going to feel the need to explain to
anyone
the abortions I've had
because I'm not going to be having any
but this is a really common guilt thing
this is a big
I would say this is a really Christian
thing now many Christians would say
that's not that's not the spirit of
Christianity what I mean is a lot of
Evangelical Christians will fear-monger
in this way
which is when the time comes for your
ultimate judgment here on Earth
you're going to repent for what you did
if you chose to have an abortion
um these folks need to move on from
something to something other than fear
except the fear works really well that's
why they keep at it
us many people not liking my uh Bill
Maher
criticisms lately
Sammy wrote in and said bro
bro you could do better than attacking
Bill Maher if you don't see wokeness as
a problem you're not looking hard enough
well remember even Bill Maher couldn't
Define wokeness he was given the
opportunity by Jake Tapper on CNN what
do you mean by woke and he said
something about Abraham Lincoln
okay uh if they want to actually explain
what they mean by woke then I'm glad to
engage with it that in in that way but
um the seeing wokeness is a problem I
don't even know what you mean by woke
and most of them don't even know what
they mean that's been something we've
looked at a number of times David says
the populace left is no better than the
populist right one tends to lead to
actual communism and the other tends to
lead to actual fascism unfortunately the
more Centrist positions require a lot
more work to maintain the leaders of
either side have to work harder to craft
something meaningful that the voters
will respond to consistently and the
voters themselves must work harder to
stay accurately informed about the
issues but that in essence is also the
key to a functioning democracy best of
luck to us but the big picture going
forward isn't very promising listen I
I don't know about populist left leads
to actual communism and I'm not sure
about that but what I will tell you is I
have called out populist rhetoric on the
left and right for a very long time
what's my main gripe with populism it's
that populism is not a policy platform
or a set of policy ideas populism is a
rhetoric and as a rhetoric it can be
used to bamboozle people
into all sorts of bad policy the example
I've used before is you know both Bernie
and Tucker will use populist sounding
rhetoric about the abandoned middle
class sounds very similar
Tucker's proposal though
is we need to do something about black
lives matter who will take your house
and brown immigrants who will take your
job right that Tucker uses the rhetoric
to suggest those as policies and so I've
said for a long time we've got to be
really careful about populist rhetoric
populism it's not really a set of policy
ideas but it is a rhetoric and it can be
used in a lot of horrible ways Joseph
left a comment on Facebook about the
Loyalty pledge that Donald Trump is
being asked to sign Joseph says Trump
could very well sign the pledge he would
want to be on the debate he wants the
attention if he doesn't end up the
Republican candidate I think he would
claim the process was rigged in some way
I think he's determined to be on the
ballot whether is the Republican
candidate or as an independent if he
becomes an independent candidate on the
ballot and he comes in third I think
everyone would finally turn against him
even the Maga freaks will turn their
backs on him if that happens maybe Trump
will finally fade away yeah I I I mean
listen guys he's 76 he'll be 78-ish at
the time of the election I think that if
Trump doesn't win the nomination uh and
or doesn't find a way to win the
presidential election his political
career is over and I know you know a lot
of people insist oh Bernie should run
again or whatever Bernie's done with
running for president I would bet money
on that
um and uh otherwise I think Joseph is
absolutely right Trump will do what he
needs to do to get on the stage and then
that is that bill posted to the
subreddit and says I don't know if this
is a touchy touchy subject in here or
not but what in the heck is David doing
with his mustache he's my favorite media
personality but this is getting out of
control he looks like a Teenage Dirtbag
it's very off-putting is he trolling
somebody I don't understand it's awful
he's a very handsome guy when he's clean
shaven but it's clear whatever he's
doing with his facial hair is 100
deliberate so I utterly perplexed by his
choice I'm sorry David but it's one of
the worst mustaches I've ever seen it
looks terrible I love this and I also
love only two-thirds of the V of the
audience agrees with this take one-third
does not folks this is satirical facial
hair satirical okay I've even got a
mullet going it's just a joke it's
satire now I've got the goatee I'm
getting a haircut in a couple days we're
gonna reboot everything just relax I'm
glad it provides entertainment but it's
really not worth getting so worked up
about but an absolutely genius if if the
message what I'm wondering is is this
message satire as well
it's uh it's awful one of the worst
mustaches I've ever seen I love it all
right and then vindo Piper via Reddit
says David
don't feed the trolls with recurring
segments about stupid YouTube comments
or emails it seems to me that David is
forgetting a cardinal rule of
interacting online don't feed the trolls
don't let them know that their idiotic
waffle bothers you don't engage at all
when you read out the ridiculous
nonsense and complain about the grammar
you're signaling they can reach you and
it affects you enough to feature in the
show don't over explain you don't need
to preempt criticisms like you just want
war with Russia or you're a communist
adapting your Viewpoint points to
anticipate the BS only encourages more
with affection from a long time viewer
ignore the wing nuts don't give them any
time or consideration end of rant yeah I
mean listen I don't agree with this a
hundred percent I agree with it 90
that's why when we do the Friday
feedback segment or whatever
um it's just we feature a small sample
of the unhinged attacks and mostly try
to focus on productive discussions I do
think that if we pretend that they don't
exist
we fall into an echo chamber
um and I don't think that that's good
so I think they should be featured
in a limited manner
handled appropriately
uh uh and in that sense
I think it's productive and a healthy
thing rather than creating yet another
Echo chamber all right send in your
thoughts info davidpackman.com leave a
YouTube comment post a tweet whatever
might be featured here make sure that
you're signed up to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show and
remember to sign up for a membership at
joinpakman.com it's the number one
funding source for the David packman
Show
joinpakman.com coupon code
please no more Trump that's the code
please no more Trump I'll see you on the
bonus show